hi everyone my name is May and welcome
to my apartment so I live in LA which
means that I kind of always have people
trying to come visit and normally I
would just have them sleep on the couch
give him a blanket or two and call it a
day but my sister's coming into town
today and I really want to make it a
special visit because I feel like we're
a little more grown up and I just want
to elevate the experience and make it a
little more comfy so today I'm going to
take this couch crash and elevate it
into something super comfy first things
first we're going to clear some space
this is a good time to move any
furniture that might be getting the way
so that your guests can have room for
themselves and their luggage I do have a
really comfortable couch and I think
most people would be fine sleeping on
there but I'm gonna go the extra mile
for my sister and I actually got a futon
so whether they're sleeping on the couch
or the futon you're always going to need
these Essentials like a clean pillow new
sheets a cozy blanket and even a little
accent pillow if you're feeling crazy
all right so now that we have the futon
set up it's looking a little more
bedroomy but I want to make it even more
comfortable so I'm actually going to put
a little nightstand here too because
something about a nightstand just gives
bedroom not living room you know so
adding to this we have a lamp and then
we're gonna plug in this power strip so
that she can charge her phone have the
little mood lighting and not have to use
a big light at night because that is
wrong and to finish off the nightstand I
have a cute eye mask some earplugs and a
nice little frame that has all the Wi-Fi
information earplugs may feel extreme
but we actually need them here because I
have a very noisy upstairs neighbor
and you cannot forget fresh towels and I
even went a little above and beyond and
got a loofah too because I really want
to be clean another place's apartment
but you know you're not sharing a loofah
I also got a couple hangers in case she
has anything fancy or anything that
might get wrinkled this is a cute little
breakfast Corner that I'm setting up for
Kai's we have all the essentials we've
got coffee tea if you're not a coffee
drinker some snacks fresh fruit and I
liked bake so I did make Tasty's lemon
blueberry yogurt muffins store-bought
things would be fine too though Kai's an
early bird and I definitely am not so
she likes to have her morning coffee and
breakfast hours before I'm even awake so
wanted to have some stuff set up for her
so she wouldn't feel like she had to
wait for me having some snacks and
drinks set up for your guests is really
nice because then they don't have to
rummage through your cabinets because
that's a little awkward sometimes and
you don't know what you can and can't
eat
my sister's almost here so we added the
final touches we have some fresh flowers
and even a little candle for the
Ambiance so let's just lighter up
There She Goes
she's here oh my gosh time for the
reveal I'm nervous but I'm excited hello
hi welcome to La thank you so much oh my
gosh do you notice anything different is
this for me yeah I set it up all for you
so you'd feel a little more at home you
know so cute and it's so much better
than last time when I was sleeping where
people were putting their butts oh what
details and it's comfy I know shockingly
comfy right that food sounds so nice and
the Wi-Fi password yeah oh my God should
have everything that you need and we
also have fresh towels I don't know what
clothes you brought but got some hangers
in case you needed to lay anything out
even got a little breakfast nook in case
you know I sleep in a lot sometimes wake
up earlier than me and so I thought that
would be kind of nice oh my gosh you're
so sweet thank you thank you so much for
watching we have some catching up to do
but if you have any other tips and
tricks on how to elevate the couch crash
for the next time she visits let us know
but for now bye
so let's just lighter up
okay so let's just light it up okay
let's just light it up no oh my God